got big topic talk about you published
ps4 pro review that's right was it last
late last week actually monday Monday
yesterday I'm okay maybe I just saw it
come through edits or something and you
assume it was gonna Friday ah cool so
you want to talk about kind of like the
games you tried on it and how they look
but also obviously like the actual
hardware about it p.m. get kindly on you
because you know a lot more about this
than I do you two would probably have
more interesting conversation than I
would between Jimmy and I but overall
impressions first like I r you I was
reading a review which is up on games by
an NGO read that right now you're saying
like if you have the extra cash laying
around you have the TV to support it
that's the key thing right it's not
gonna be crazy noticeable if you're just
planning on like a regular HD like 10 a
TV right so I would say if you have a 4k
HDR TV and don't have a console and are
looking to buy one like PlayStation 4
pro is a must buy pretty much in my
opinion um if you do have a ps4 I
generally would not upgrade unless you
have an HDR 4k TV and have the extra
cash lying around so what is it like
there's some things that you and Jake
Decker I believe went to talk to mark
cerny about how its able to run for K
because it there's like a loophole that
allows you to run them it's like we're
good so they're calling it so the
playstation 4 pro it can do native 4k
and some games i believe the last of us
is doing native 4k but most games are
going to be you know using what they
call checkerboard rendering which is a
4k rendering shortcut that looks pretty
close not quite as good but is less
graphic demanding okay not I mean is it
too like delving into minus should I
talk about how it was and so basically
spatially takes up the same resolution
space as 3840 x 2160p but it has half
the shaders and it does it places the
shaders in like a checkerboard fashion
okay and apparently doing so is an
effective shortcut okay interesting um
so what other less I from like the HDR
the 4k capabilities what are there any
other drawers to getting this console
aside from linkage the visual updates
and whatnot yeah so it depends on how
developers want to use extra processing
power but some games could instead of
like pushing a higher resolution
and HDR they could bolster frame rates
for instance some games could you know
run at 60 words before they they didn't
and some games like shadow of mordor
push you know better graphical fidelity
so it wasn't super noticeable when I
tried it on that game but I did notice
like you know extra wrinkles on faces
and things like that this is definitely
feel like it's fitting into the
narrative of like a mid generation
upgrade versus like a new console like
obviously it's not that big of a
difference so that kind of answers the
question but like as someone you know
just using a console it's better than
the previous one like where does it fall
for you in terms of that identity yeah I
would say it's somewhere in between a
console traditional kontol refresh and
like a next-generation console it's
somewhere in between there well yeah
basically what I noticed like for my
tests so far and granite they weren't
too many games that supported the
previous ps4 pro enhancements although
more coming I think on the tenth when
actually launches generally the the
thing that I noticed was that but you
get better anti-aliasing especially a 4k
although you kind of notice it at 1080p
as well and interestingly enough colors
look different on the ps4 pro in certain
HDR games and that's interesting because
the ps4 the base ps4 also sports HDR but
with both consoles you know running HDR
I noticed the cover of the colors were
more vibrant on the pros still yeah when
we're I was at the Sony reveal event New
York a couple months ago and naughty
dogs that are showing both uncharted 4
and the last of us and when they showed
on chart for is when Drake was
underwater and like a reef and it
appeared to myself and someone else was
it was like I don't someone else was
saying that it looked like the older
footage was it was it looked worse than
I remember seeing you just played
uncharted 4 in March and it looked much
worse when I saw on their TV and then
they pressed a button for this bill that
was just a button to switch to the ps4
pro graphics mmm colors look much more
vibrant but yeah I just again seen that
old footage like I have to watch our
comparison videos it like you you worked
on a bunch of comparison video yeah
that's why I want to talk about also i'm
in terms of a like we can go back to the
hardware side if we want to but in terms
of the games you know you mentioned
shadow Mordor titanfall 2 i believe was
like released with ps4
Pro support it didn't have the patch
when I tested it although okay it's
getting it soon okay interesting maybe
that's why I took so long to download
didn't take like a while to download for
you to titanfall to don't remember man
no nevermind i thought we'd had ranted
about this I don't know something but I
do i do believe that i mean i wasn't
there at the new york event but i do
believe that the last of us and
uncharted probably did look as accurate
as it did and that's basically what
happens when you look at something
that's like marginally better yeah um
like when you look at the old version
it's like oh wow it actually looked like
that it's like try going back and
looking out like a 480p like TV is like
well i actually like watch that for like
several years it looks pretty bad now
sure um as far as like developing
psychos is it up to the developers
whether they worked it into do this or
like sucker punch has it with second son
but that game came out 2013 same with
shadow shadow muertos 2014 yeah like
some of these games are pretty old I
guess it's like a few years old by how
do they decide whether to support the
games well if you look back at the
conversation you have a cerny right I
mean he kind of stated that like look
our target for how much extra work this
is going to take is like oh point three
percent of like the overall told me he
was gonna take one programmer roughly
three weeks right and so in my mind and
I've then tell me what you think to like
that's probably just because a lot of
times this is just changing a setting in
the the rendering engine right like it's
not really like the rebuilding the whole
game and like you know a really
intricate way it's kind of just like it
will bump up the anti-aliasing or will a
neighbor will enable this and then we
just have to bug test it right yeah I
mean he made it he made it sound like
they were developing the ecosystem to
make it easy for developers to to patch
right um and yeah games will have to be
patched to support the pro enhancements
they won't work right out of the box and
because you know they're giving game
developers the freedom to use extra
processing power you know as they see
fit it can be a bit confusing as to what
the games will you know get with the
update like I said like I mentioned some
games will have faster frame rates some
games will you know I've higher
resolution resolution textures or you
know just basically better graphical
settings the same dilemma every
developer faces there when they release
their game sun console you know people
say a console can't run this game at 30
or at 60 frames per second
game and it's like right because the
developer wanted the game to look so
good that it's then taking up so much
power it's not yeah depending on the
console is dependent on the developer
just confusing me because it seems like
an easy win if it would take one program
at three weeks since just to work on
this patch what do they what do they
want though do they want the game to
just look pretty or do they want to turn
faster like right at the same time
though it's like if you have if you've
released this game that's like 34 years
old or whatever three years old is it
worth it to you to go back and send a
programmer to you know spend time like
recoding it or whatever reap a Qing it
because you know the games like sitting
in bargain bins right now and you know
is that a good use of your time yeah
it's kind of an interesting question too
right yeah I don't I mean like like
again reading a review you said like
overall if you have a ps4 just I mean if
you have the PS or the 4k HDR TV is
supported then go for it it might be
worth it especially don't have a ps4 but
uh I don't know from what we know now of
i don't know how much this would be
speculation but from what we know this
scorpio does this seem like the scorpio
might be a bigger improvement over the
xbox one then this is over the ps4 did
we not even know enough to say on paper
from what we know which isn't that much
it seems like it also Microsoft is
jabbing Sony saying it isn't like a true
4k system whereas theirs is because
that's just actually running like native
4k right that's what they're asserting
so far from what I can tell okay so yeah
interesting there's one thing I want to
point out about second Sun which is
interesting it supports HDR and on the
ps4 pro version the colors look much
more lifelike than the base ps4 and but
it's not always perfect either because
like the black levels look really black
which is a nice aspect of HDR but at the
same time it looked almost too dark in
turn cases like the character would walk
in in between like Demi late hallways
and like he'd almost disappear because
he's like just covered in shadows okay
interesting I mean I I could not tell
you what that game looks like I I play
that game I don't even I'd have to
really look at the comparison video see
what the differences are exciting played
that in such a long time sounds like a
remaster I guess at this point been to
me um yeah in general like I don't know
Petey thing you're gonna get a pro
eventually yeah totally dr give a 4k TV
or well no but the plan
is like once I get that TV yes I will
get that and like we've me my girlfriend
been running the same TV for years so
the time is come and to actually have a
console come out that is like gonna
support it like you've surprised as I am
to see that that's the impetus for me to
actually start thinking about this I
mean my end goal is to yes get a TV and
get this oh cool yeah so Jimmy your ps4
pro review is up on gamespot com if I
you're interested in reading that go
check that out with a video review for
it too or nickel video review up on
YouTube and GameSpot so let us know what
you think are you going to get this do
you have a ps4 do you want to upgrade do
you not even have ps4 and just want this
what do you think about this compare the
Scorpio let us know in the comments
below